some say it's an alien others say a
military experiment it's also been
called a dinosaur a humanoid a robot and
even the devil itself earning its name
from its favorite prey the goatsucker
el chupacabras stalks the countryside
and cities alike chupacabras are a
popular folk legend but not everyone
knows there are two different versions
of the monster reports of El chupacabras
occur everywhere from Puerto Rico where
actually originated to Maine whenever
one is sighted or found dead the
international press latches on to the
story with the same intensity as the
bloodsucker itself some believe it is a
freak of nature others are convinced it
was a culmination of mass hysteria but
it's said to be a monster that doesn't
normally hunt humans so why are we so
afraid of it
I'm dr. Emily szarka and this is
monstrum
the first reports of El chupacabras are
actually relatively recent as monsters
go it's not your typical classic monster
this one is modern they first appeared
in 1995 in the puerto rican town of con
Ivana's there were reports of the deaths
of dozens of farm animals whose blood
had apparently been sucked dry by small
perforations in the neck and abdomen it
caused immediate panic no animal was
safe
ducks rabbits chickens pigs and yes
goats were all said to have been killed
by a grotesque creature in Puerto Rico
chupacabras are said to be three to five
feet tall with wings like a bat fangs a
hunched back large black or red eyes and
covered with either scales or quills
some reports include tiny arms and the
ability to jump great distances others
claim it has spikes along its back and a
long tongue for the residents of con
Ivana's in 1995 this terrifying monster
was a real threat their livestock were
dying and people were so scared that
guards were positioned to protect what
animals were left children were escorted
to school and some families even
abandoned their homes as local and
national papers picked up the story
reports increased across the island by
April 1996 more than 2,000 animals had
fallen victim to el chupacabras at
different times porto rico housed US
military personnel this includes Fort
Buchanan located less than 40 minutes
from can Ivana's rumors swirled that el
chupacabras was an escaped military
experiment this is where things get more
interesting and political mayor Jose
Ramon Kimo Soto who was up for
re-election in 1996 decided to take
matters into his own hands and protect
the people and animals of his town with
a safari in October 1995 Soto organized
200 people including armed cops and set
out to catch the monster dude literally
dragged a goat around in a cage and
carried a large crucifix the press
dubbed him Kimo Jones Soto also loved to
give interviews and when the
International English speaking press
heard of the chupacabras in late 1995
his quotes appeared in the Washington
Post the New York time
and this fun one soda wasn't the only
politician to address el chupacabras the
Puerto Rican government decided to step
in they were not only concerned for
their people and their livelihoods they
also recognized the negative impact the
monster could have on tourism biologists
were brought in to find scientific
explanation for the attacks theories
ranged widely some think it was caused
by bats driven by droughts to seek new
food sources
others say roving packs of wild dogs or
even escaped rhesus monkeys that had
been imported for scientific testing one
zoologist believe the majority of the
attacks were caused by a spike in the
Mongoose population don't let their
cuteness fool you those things are nuts
fun fact even though Puerto Ricans are
citizens of the United States and must
obey all of its laws they don't have the
right to vote in the presidential
election they're asked to obey federal
laws but have little power to change
them technically Puerto Rico is a
Commonwealth of the United States
so Puerto Ricans at least based on their
lack of voting rights are outsiders in
their own country which just seems crazy
to me what is this Victorian England
despite all of this or perhaps because
of it el chupacabras became a pop
culture phenomenon for some Puerto
Ricans the monster became an antihero
a monstrous symbol for their own other
nests and relation to the United States
by the end of 1995 thousands of shirts
were printed with illustrations of
chupacabras it inspired three songs
[Music]
and a cocktail in the early 2000s a
different kind of Chupacabra emerged
reports from Mexico and the southwestern
United States described el chupacabras
as a hairless gaunt animal walking on
four legs
a vast departure from the original
puerto rican monster unlike the puerto
rican version actual corpses have been
found upon examination these canine
looking creatures always turn out to be
coyotes dogs or raccoons with genetic
abnormalities or victims of mange an
animal infected with mange has severe
itching and hair loss some even have
self-inflicted wounds from scratching
and chewing in advanced cases the skin
of the animal will become thicker and
darker in color and their body may be
emaciated all of these symptoms can
explain the chupacabras appearance
because this chupacabra is based on
real-world animals it carries less
cultural significance than its Puerto
Rican cousin the unique political status
of Puerto Rico helped to shape the El
chupacabras myth it became a symbol of
cultural other nests and the mystery
surrounding its origin emphasized how
those in power can control information
one thing both myths have in common is
that real animals are actually dying for
farmers and rural citizens the threat to
their livelihoods is a huge very real
problem monster mythologies are
typically thought of as ancient tales
told long ago but El chupacabras shows
us that these stories can arise today
they highlight our fascination with
trying to explain the unexplained and
allow us to tell our cultural histories
by merging fact and fiction I can't help
but wonder what form will the
chupacabras take next thanks for
watching monstrum have you ever seen all
chupacabras let me know in the comments
and don't forget to subscribe
you